as they do every December European
fisheries ministers will try to clinch
agreement on fishing opportunities for
next year for certain stocks in EU and
some non EU waters at their Council in
Brussels this annual process is based on
recommendations from the European
Commission taking into account
scientific advice it concerns stocks in
the Atlantic the North Sea International
fishing where EU vessels take part and
in the black sea fishing opportunity
limits are aimed at keeping stocks
sustainable they take the form of total
allowable catches or tax for each stock
and each fishing zone tax are then
divided into quotas between member
states the Commission will also brief
ministers on the way the fishing landing
obligation is being implemented the
rules are part of recent reform to the
common fishing policy and will enter
force in January to ensure that less
fish are thrown away meanwhile the
Italian presidency will report to
agriculture ministers on progress
achieved during the second half of this
year on the legislative proposals like a
review of organic farming legislation
the school fruit vegetable and milk
scheme official controls and plant
health they'll also exchanged views on
the future of the dairy sector notably
on price volatility in the market and
ways to limit the impact of the Russian
banner Europe on dairy produce the
Commission for its part will present the
main sections of its simplification
agenda for farm policy it aimed at
keeping down costs to farmers and other
operators in the sector